you wrote an article a week ago that I'm
guessing you didn't intend or didn't
expect to get quite as much attention as
it did
I really really did not I had been
working on the article men are lost for
a couple months beforehand and I knew
that there was sort of growing
discussion about the crisis of men in
general you know I'd read Richard Reeves
book I've been following Scott gallo and
others on their podcasts but it seems
like the piece was almost the permission
that some people needed to finally talk
about the issue out in the open and they
were like really surprised to see it in
a mainstream publication too and also at
length I will admit that it is quite
long
um but I've been really excited by the
response
I think the reason that it needed to be
so long is because having this
discussion is so far away from the
typical cultural Zeitgeist that you have
to take people there one step at a time
you know Richard Reeves talks about this
he has to prostrate himself on the we're
not saying that women shouldn't have
their focus on them and we we are not
trying to take away any and we must
remember that the problems of the LGBT
trans Community are also and finally
after we've gone through this big
rigmarole we can actually get to the
conversation of talking about men so
there is no such thing as having a short
article about the crisis of Modern Men
because it leaves so many holes that
people who want to interpret it in an
ungenerous light are just immediately
going oh so you think that such and such
it's like no obviously not
yeah yeah you have to leave space for
all of the caveats and the like not
necessarily shout outs to different
groups like and we're acknowledging that
this kind of man and like that kind of
woman etc etc but I mean it was also
long for me at least and honestly it was
longer my editors did cut it down
because there are just so many different
threads
um that are coming together in this
question uh another columnist at the
post wrote to me and she was like you
know it almost feels like you could draw
a dotted line from just like this
question of what's happening with men to
kind of everything that's happening in
our moments whether it's like politics
or religion or like all these different
Trends so there are just so many kind of
angles to this question and sources of
discontent and maybe solutions that it's
hard to fit it into one piece I guess
that's why Richard wrote a book
what is happening with men nowadays
well we I mean we throw around the the
phrase the crisis of masculinity
um but I I actually do think that there
is a crisis I mean explaining it out is
also a long process too because again so
many factors but basically we can start
by saying that Society has changed a lot
over the past 30 to 40 years and many of
those challenges have been great for
some groups for women especially
um but they have not necessarily been so
great for men especially working
classmen but men of all kinds seem to be
feeling a sort of malaise I mean we can
tick off a couple of Statistics right
when it comes to Education First women
were finally allowed to go to college
which is great
um very supportive of that but right now
in most colleges we're seeing that women
you know outnumber men hugely for every
100 undergraduate degrees Bachelor
bachelor's degrees that women get men
only get 70 before and you know we saw a
huge wave of kind of college dropouts
basically during the covid-19 pandemic
when you look at the data 70 of those
who just sort of like gave up and left
school were men
um you can look at health statistics so
you know we've talked about deaths of
Despair that's from suicide
alcohol-induced illness or drug overdose
three out of four deaths of Despair are
men
um you can talk about you know wages and
workplace achievement so wages have
stagnated for men since basically the
1970s either stagnated or fallen for all
men but the men at you know the top of
the economic ladder
um and I think that this has just huge
ramifications for how men feel about
their place in the world or rather don't
feel about their place in the world
women are thriving the economy is moving
away from sort of labor-intensive jobs
towards jobs that reward soft skills and
social skills and credentials and
many men are feeling a little bit lost
like they are not sure what role they
play especially when you know there are
these kind of traditional archetypes
that men used to play in our society of
you know protector provider especially
and now 50 of women say they make as
much as or more than their partner
um women can have children by themselves
through artificial reproductive
technology
um and then of course the lgbtq movement
has achieved more Acceptance in society
but it also seems to have kind of made
the question of gender even more unclear
if you can change your gender if sex
doesn't really mean anything what what
does it mean to be a man actually
and so a lot of young men especially are
feeling as I said lost
um like they don't know where to fit and
they're kind of looking for role models
of what a man should be or could be in
this moment and coming up short except
for some pretty bad examples which I
also talk about in the piece yeah
there's an interesting one-two punch I
think that that has kind of happened the
first being a structural change that has
disadvantaged young men or at least
meant that they have been able to take
advantage of their talents quite as much
you mentioned we've gone from a Brawn
base to a brain-based economy
credentialism is much more important now
conscientious and excuse female girls
are better at sitting still through the
time that the teenagers and adolescents
and remembering to get their homework in
on time two to one basically females to
males completing a four-year U.S college
degree it gets even worse if you look at
Masters level seven times more men
dropped out of college during covert
than women did so you know all of these
things on top has created um a
structural environment in which men
aren't exactly thriving and then this
sort of second punch has been a loss
culturally I think of their position of
what does it mean to be a man you know
if gender is Up For Debate and if you're
biological sex and the person that you
show up as in the world is available to
be discussed then what does it mean to
be a man like literally that question
you know there's a very famous
documentary called what is a woman but
what is a man is an equally valid
question when we're talking about the
roles of men and it's not just I am a
man who has this sort of physical
biological manifestation it's the
symbolic representation of what does it
mean how should I show up what do the
archetypes and the virtues and the
values that I should rely on what are
the things that when times get tough I
should believe in myself you know what
is greater than me the grand narrative
that explains my life as a male and it's
that one too that I think has caused a
lot of men to feel very dispossessed
they they feel like they're not really
getting much sympathy
um I think you have this really really
great quote where you say many young men
feel their difficulties are often
dismissed out of hand as whining from a
patriarchy that they don't feel a part
of and it definitely seems like modern
manner sort of being made to pay for the
sins of the advantages of their fathers
and grandfathers whilst not really
feeling like they get any themselves now
yeah I that was a big part of what I
wanted to talk about in this piece
because I think another Factor that's
making men feel
dispossessed or not sure of what they
belong to set our culture has also
shifted
um and I think many of these ships have
been good things again like it's it's
great that we've recognized that you
know sexual assault is real but you need
to get consent the metoo movement was a
good thing
um it outed a lot of predators at the
same time I think especially in
in media culture and in Progressive
spaces frankly there's been this
reflexive push to say you know the
future is female
men suck like men are garbage
masculinity is toxic
um those are kind of acceptable things
to to say now and you know telling
somebody that the person they are like
that they are toxic
um obviously doesn't make them feel good
obviously doesn't make them feel
accepted by uh society and you know when
you say okay men are toxic men are toxic
masculinity is toxic
what's what's the alternative like what
does a good masculinity look like and
that picture isn't really being made
very clear I mean you look at media
representations of men and you know even
popular TV shows and I feel like the
most common archetype right now is like
the male schlub he lives in his mom's
basement and just simply something
Griffin right yeah they're not like
Father figures that one looks up to or
respects they're sort of people you
would make fun of or look down on
um and I feel like this this comes at I
think
the expense of a productive dialogue
actually it pushes men out of the
conversation and opens up a space of
vulnerability that you know is is often
filled by Bad actors it's also not
really I think Fair actually
um but you were gonna say something yeah
just that Richard Reeves again talked
about this he taught me about this over
a year ago now uh where he said that as
soon as you throw out the term toxic
masculinity it causes so many men to
just check out of the conversation if
you're going to tell me that there is
something in me which is like original
sin and it needs to be expunged from me
I need to I need to be exercised of my
toxic masculinity
what do you think what like you're
really going to allow you really expect
men to engage in a conversation after
the first thing you've done is say that
a core part of them is something that's
inherently toxic and yeah you know
putting forward the um a positive view
for men has been as
uh the decrease in that has been the
same I would say almost perfectly in
line with the increase in what I would
class as a patronizing view of women's
success so uh the difference between the
two Mulan films is a perfect example of
this in the first one she's small and
and not as strong but she's crafty and
she she works harder and she overcomes
and she uses her size to her advantage
and through hard work and determination
she tells a tale of someone with a
disadvantage that overcomes it to now be
as good or even better than people who
had more advantages than them you look
at the most recent Milan film and she's
just born to be perfect she's more
talented the only restriction that she
ever faces is that the men don't believe
in her enough and that there's some sort
of Oppression out there or the second
doctor strange film where the uh Central
American daughter of a lesbian couple
has the most power in the entire world
and the only reason that she doesn't
have it is because she doesn't believe
in herself enough like that to me is not
an inspiring story to tell young women
either like you know we need to be able
to build a society with resilient girls
who have archetypes that they can look
up to too who overcame difficult things
who don't expect the world to bend to
their every whim and that if they do
encounter any sort of difficulty that
this is like an aberration that this is
the sign that there's something wrong
with the world it's like no this is
baked into what the world is the world
is a series of challenges
so I think that we it's been this very
interesting like men and women have
almost sort of like passed each other
and high-fived or maybe not high-fived
on the way past
um where the role models for men have
become increasingly less inspirational
ostensibly the role models for women
have become more inspirational but I
don't actually think that they are I
think that it's like a very fragile
thinly veiled form of like
um pedestalization
yeah that's that's such an interesting
example I mean
I did a lot of interviews with young men
for this piece
um and one thing that a guy who I
mentioned at the end of this piece his
name is Ronan Bray said to me really
stood out you know he was talking about
Role Models
um and where he saw messages about how
to be a man and he was like you know I
see all of this stuff for women now like
women you can be astronauts you can be
scientists you can be race car drivers
you can do everything and that's really
cool but at the same time I I hear as a
man like men this is what you shouldn't
do get out of the way stop talking over
women and holding them back but there's
no like kind of positive
like things that you can be for men it
seems to have all transferred and then
also I think you're on to something too
when you talk about this sort of almost
thin thin veneer that is on some of
these aspirational messages that are
that are given to women I think one
other thing that we see in our
Our Moment our modern moment is
an ethos of gender neutrality
um an idea that actually gender doesn't
matter we shouldn't talk about it women
can do anything that men can do men can
do anything that women can do really you
don't need to be a good man or a good
woman there's no such thing just be a
good person we're all kind of the same
just be a good one and
I find that rather grating because I I
simply don't believe that's realistic or
that useful a most people don't want to
live in an androgynous Society where
everyone is the same but B I think that
there is something
specific about the embodied existence of
being a man or a woman and there's lots
of overlap in sort of personality traits
and physical traits and things that the
the two Sexes share but there are also
differences and part of being a good man
or a good woman in my opinion at least
is kind of recognizing those differences
and recognizing one's strengths
weaknesses skills Etc and figuring out
how to use those specific to you traits
well and so if you're a man like it's
likely that you are probably stronger
than women and old ladies so being a
good man you know would suggest that you
figure out what your duties and
responsibilities are when it comes to
that thing about being a man not just
being like well we're all just be good
yeah it's it's so uh you're right to say
as well this is a commonly rolled out
criticism of people that say ah men and
women they're more similar than they are
different and you go well if you look at
some traits on their own yes yes but
there is tons and tons of overlap in the
middle of the distribution some of them
like strength for instance hand strength
it basically they don't touch that like
the weakest man and the strongest woman
on average would be like basically even
they wouldn't be close to each other
but when you actually fold them all
together when you look at the suite of
traits overall when it's not just
aggression but it's also height and it's
neuroticism and its extroversion it's
conscientiousness and it's the
these things just separate out and this
isn't because of socialization this is
because of inbuilt innate biological
differences now are they perpetuated
through culture yeah absolutely but
where do you think the culture came from
culture wasn't just created out of
nothing it was built off the back of a
biological framework and you're right as
well it is the difference between trying
to make men and women equal and trying
to make men and women the same it's
aiming for androgyny rather than
equality and that has been a very rapid
slippery slope to say well there are no
differences and because
men held positions of uh esteem and
Advantage for quite a long time
what I think it made was almost like an
echo that almost taught women or people
that were pro-women that because men had
held these positions
the way to get those positions of
Advantage was for women to emulate the
men things that men were doing yeah
precisely yeah so I wrote a book
um rethinking sex a provocation it came
out last spring
um and it was basically about our sexual
culture and our relationship culture and
questions of consent and sexual ethics
but this is one thing that I spent a lot
of time thinking about and writing about
in the book actually
this idea that the feminist movement
kind of shifted over time in a way that
I don't necessarily think was positive
you know original feminists were what
they said really was that you know women
are important women should be respected
as much as men are respected women
should be allowed to partake in society
as much as men are but women should also
be respected
as women for being themselves and then
solely over the years we've shifted
through this kind of like Playboy to
girl boss culture where it's like okay
well men have a lot of power and in fact
honestly kind of the worst men tend to
have a lot of power to be a successful
woman just be more like the most
powerful man who's often like the worst
kind of men and so it's like women
be a girl boss which is still a boss
like instead of being a Playboy you're
just a Playgirl yeah you're just like
picking up the same things instead of
being respected for like your your
actual self and that hasn't been healthy
for women either
um but when the same thing is asked if
men you know it's not healthy for them
themselves no I think modern feminism
told women that true Freedom was
achieved by working like your father and
having sex like your brother
I think that that's and I know that
you're friends with Louise Perry and
Mary Harrington
um and I was chatting to both of them a
lot over the last year about this very
topic and you know the the failings of
modern feminism and what it really
hasn't given to women that it maybe had
the opportunity to and then how it's
also you know to bring it back to the
men conversation I think a lot of men
see feminism as overreaching from equal
from Beyond equality into uh retribution
I think that they they feel like
feminism uh and it seems to me like
there is a a good amount of like women
out there who would class themselves as
feminists that are almost looking to get
one over on men because now there are
um upper hands culturally that that
could perhaps be used to push uh a
particular sort of narrative and it
doesn't surprise me that that men feel
like dispossessed from that movement too
which creates this like recursive
antagonism between the Sexes that men
feel like that they're being mistreated
and women are the only ones whose
problems are being seen so I'm going to
either Retreat or become more misogynist
which means that I'm going to retreat
further which means that they're going
to dislike me more
and it keeps on going and going and
going so going back to sort of the the
conversation the cultural milieu around
this why why are people struggling to
advocate for the problems of poison men
so easily well so really quickly just
there are some data points that actually
totally support your thesis about this
that's retributive I knew it I knew it
wasn't just Bro Science I knew it wasn't
yeah no I mean a recent survey came out
that showed that um among gen Z men
right now in America fewer than half of
them would say that feminism has been
good for American society which is a
pretty startling statistic actually so
gnz the the like
consideration yeah precisely yeah and
then there was a survey done by ipsos it
was a global survey about sort of the
state of gender relations around the
world but you can isolate out countries
and in the United States I think it was
43 of men agreed with exactly the
statement you made that the push for
women's equality has gone so far that it
has turned into discrimination against
men and so almost half of men in America
apparently think this which is something
that should be maybe a little bit
alarming to women and to progressives to
anyone who wants cooperation between the
Sexes
um but that kind of leads to to your
next question you know why is this
discourse so hard to have in society
um
you know that was one of the tough
things about writing this piece in a way
because kind of as you were saying at
the beginning like you want to respect
all sides and you also don't want to be
read as something other than what you
are
um I think that there is
first of all
an unfortunate tendency in politics and
American politics specifically to view
things as very zero sum
um you know like okay well
we have spent some time helping women
you know the feminist movement has
succeeded in some ways but the gains are
still really fragile you know as we saw
uh when the Dobbs decision came down and
abortion rights were rolled back
um we saw this during the covid-19
pandemic like women had entered the
workforce and then they just started
dropping out because they didn't have
support during covet 19. so there's this
feeling that like okay we've kind of
just started moving forward for women if
we turn our attention to men now then I
guess we're just women are over like
women are not going to get anything
anymore we're not going to focus on them
and so there's a resistance to changing
the focus because it's dude like we can
either help one sex or help the other I
don't think that's true in fact I think
that the Sexes rely on each other to to
support each other and if one is in its
flop era the other one's going to be in
trouble too
um
I also think that there is
an unfortunate like mixed Association so
the right has really
um like the political right has kind of
been first to the men question
um and sort of right leaning or
right-coded influencers have been the
ones to talk about men's issues the most
and unfortunately some of them have used
you know talking about men's issues as
an excuse to say like well what we
really need to do to help men and to
give them jobs again is to put women
back into the home you know and you know
it's actually it's a bad thing that
women can provide for themselves right
now so we need to like
make sure that women have to get married
to be economically successful like that
sort of thing and no one really
progressives I think many people
moderates don't want to be associated
with that and there's a feeling that if
you start talking about men there's kind
of like a sideways look that one gets
where it's like oh are you like oh
you're one of those yeah
there is 100 a branding problem for
men's advice at the moment I mean it's
one of the advantages uh of a black
woman that you know you are able to make
say things without uh jumping through
quite so many Hoops or caveats then I
would with the way that I present right
every single time that I that I come on
to have a conversation like this someone
in the comments that has never seen my
stuff before and doesn't actually know
what I talk about will accuse me of
being a budget Andrew Tate I'm like look
I am I am that's right so I am so blue
pilled in the eyes of manosphere that I
I'm a cook but I'm so bigoted in the
eyes of Guardian readers that I'm
unspeakable so really really managing to
to slice through the middle there but
that's another reason why even though
I've spoken about men women the problems
that we're facing at the moment with
masculinity and dating for a long time
never ever once identified with the
manosphere despite the fact that like
ostensibly I should do right like if the
manosphere means anything it means
people talking to men online about the
problems that men face and like how to
be a good man you are literally doing
that and yet yet branding problem
massive branding problem
yeah totally and
I mean that was an interesting thing
about publishing this piece too right
like I kind of began to feel that I I
honestly do think that it is that you're
totally right it is the case that
someone like me kind of had to write
this piece to be taken seriously
um but at the same time I kind of am
feeling a little bit of blowback for men
who read the piece they're like what a
woman talking about a men's business she
has she knows nothing I'm not gonna read
this and it's it's like funny to get
that response from from both sides so
it's I can only imagine actually trying
to
be taken seriously a male disadvantage
the male disadvantage that you're facing
here some toxic misandry yeah so this is
something that I've noticed a lot right
um especially over the last couple of
months why is it the case that the
conversation about masculinity and
mainstream media is being so dominated
by women it's a comment on the state of
discourse that most of the voices are
being given mainstream platforms about
masculinity all of them almost all of
them are women there was that the
masculinity issue that got released by
Politico did you read that I did and
it's all women yeah yep no it's like
seven articles seven different essays
not single man anywhere on there like
you know and also the fact that your
piece has resonated so much suggests
this is an issue to anybody that doesn't
think that there is a problem with men
at the moment explain to me why this
article of yours has exploded but yeah
what what do you think is going on here
is it just the the softly softly
acceptable fluffy face of being able to
talk about men's problems without being
accused of being a budget Andrew Tate is
that are you the thin end of the wedge
so that this conversation
you're a gateway drug you're a gateway
drug yeah I don't I don't I hope not but
maybe I don't know
um
that's a that is a really interesting
question
um and it's something that honestly I
want to sit with in more detail I have a
okay what I'm gonna say now is
theoretical
um so this is just like me spinning on a
class no science that's fine that's the
best fight
chick science Girl science
um whatever you find
yeah uh
so I think that
when you're looking for
examples of positive masculinity
um
the best and
most positive masculine examples or men
are usually not just out there talking
about themselves and their problems in
the Public Square like that's kind of
not what they do they're just sort of
they go about their business
um so that's one thing and often the
people in the manosphere like the
loudest people the Andrew Tates and to
some extent Jordan Peterson who really
you know started from a place where I
was like oh interesting and now is
maybe a little off the rails
um you note that they are kind of
unusual rather attention wanting figures
and that is that is why they are in
public
um I would also say perhaps that it has
something to do with just
media culture overall
um I think media is a slightly more
feminized space maybe or at least like
like
almost soft commentary
space like when we're talking about
questions of like
society and social cues and social norms
um that space seems to be heavier on the
female lens than
other spaces might be
um
and then
let's see what was what was my last
my last take on this one
um I mean in general I also think that
not not necessarily in the media space
but in general
um and sorry if this is very gender
essentialistic me but I do think that
women spend more time
thinking about these sort of like social
cues and gender cues and not necessarily
taking them for granted you know there
is sort of a whole sphere of academic
study now that's that's women's studies
and it's just about how identities are
formed what they look like
um
and my senses that men don't spend as
much time thinking in the abstract about
like what do our friendships and
communities look like like what is the
space here
um and so like that sort of analysis
often false women and then the last
thing actually and maybe this is
most relevant to me but you know I
started thinking about this question a
long time ago but my thinking about like
wait what is going on here was
supercharged when I started writing
about sex and relationships and dating
culture which women I think definitely
talk more about and have more space to
write about and I think that is the
place where the issue of like what is
going on with men exactly we need to
figure that out because they're really
kind of either acting up or not acting
at all like became very obvious to women
who are like trying to date men
and being like why is everyone so
terrible all of a sudden or not all of a
sudden something has changed what is it
and so women Maybe started thinking
about this earlier in some sense there's
some there's some incredible percentage
of psychologists that are female it's
like like 70 plus percent I think of
psychologists to female and broadly the
the closest area I think that we're
talking to around this is in the world
of evolutionary psychology it's
behavioral genetics it's social sciences
you know it's the integration of what we
are and the world culture how does that
all work and you know that I guess maybe
is even in terms of Academia dominated
by women I would I wouldn't disagree
that women probably do have a uh
predisposition toward
thinking about people rather than things
and I think that this even though it's
kind of a things abstract conversation
is more people than it is thingsy
um but I I also agree that the the
conversation about dating was what got
me into the thinking about masculinity
and men's issues too and you touch on
this really really well in your piece
which is
um to the extent that any vision of
non-toxic masculinity is proposed it
ends up sounding more like stereotypical
femininity than anything else the
problem being that even the women who
support this narrative probably don't
want to have sex with the men who are
following it and there is an issue that
the men who women are hoping to date
kind of aren't there even why that while
those same women may be sort of carrying
the cards in the placards saying that
they want more of them around it's a
very odd sort of
um juxtaposition there's some definitely
some cognitive dissonance going on there
I think
yeah totally I mean I even say in the
piece that you know when Scott Galloway
said something like that I cringed in
recognition
um and this is something that's come up
as I've as I've discussed the piece even
with men where it's like okay well women
do want like men who are sensitive and
aware and you know etc etc and then the
guys are like do you really because it
kind of seems like women always date Bad
Boys
um and I don't actually think that
that's exactly true but they're there
there is something to the limits do as I
say not as I do maybe that's not that's
not exactly as I do not as I say yeah
basically yeah
it's funny there's
um a friend of mine who's a writer uh
for a conservative magazine and I have
like joked about this where she's like
you know I meet all these liberal women
who say that they want a guy who like
opens doors and like is works out
whatever it's like maybe you need to
start dating conservatives that's a
conservative that's what a conservative
is called yeah well you saw that article
when uh super viral a couple of weeks
ago which is like a liberal girl
realized that the only guys that she
found attractive had the opposite set of
political beliefs to the ones that she
did and you know there's a really great
study from Catherine salmon she looked
at the um front cover models of dark
romance
um you know you have Fifty Shades of
Gray comes out it kind of breaks open
this entire new literary genre I'm
someone who's been on the cover of like
10 or more dark romance novels so I can
speak from this as a position of
authority wait really
yeah yeah I I went through everything
really went through a brief period of
that didn't realize before I actually
did it I didn't realize that that person
wasn't just a cool image on the front
but it's actually supposed to be the
protagonist and then after I got my
first one and it got USA Today something
something Kerry Lake it's called
Ricochet if people want to Google it
um there's a lot more I'm not going to
give you those but my mum my mum asked
me for a copy of it and I was like mum
like this is not Harry Potter like I
don't think she knew she was like oh my
son's on the front cover of a novel like
that's so amazing I'm like no
mum I'm not having you read this dark
romance thing with me on the front of
your son anyway we are sidetracked by a
disgusting image
um
they tried during so you have 50 Shades
breaks everything open dark romance
comes out then in the early 2010s there
is a pushback against why do we need to
have these you know Lumberjack men or
like the like big buff policemen or
whatever or the billionaire on the front
cover we should put more sort of
feminized more agreeable men on the
front cover and they did
and the books didn't sell the books
didn't sell well because even though
that might be publicly what is popular
for
um women to uphold and pedestalize
that's not necessarily what they're
attracted to there is a caveat here to
add in which is the thing that you want
to fantasize about is not necessarily
the thing that you want to marry and
there's a big difference there you know
like men too like she's for the streets
is all well and good if it's not for a
one-night stand right like she's not for
the streets if she's ready willing and
able so both men and women
um
fantasize sexually about things that
they don't necessarily optimize for when
it comes to a long-term relationship so
it's not strictly true right like there
are certain things that women may even
optimize against like the hyper
masculine side the super disagreeable
man may be very sexually arousing but
not super uh useful to being a long-term
relationship with because it would
probably do your heading but yeah my
point being that
stated and revealed preferences
sometimes Clash up against each other
yeah and there is something interesting
too about sort of subtle and ambient
pressure to State a certain preference
that you may not even hold right
um I think you know we talk about our
society and there is a sort of a bias
towards and I think in in some ways this
can be a good bias towards inclusivity
towards a sort of
non-gendered like open rolled uh
positive inclusive atmosphere where
anyone can do whatever they want and so
even if you are a woman who like I don't
know wants a super masculine looking you
know like cover boy hunk like
to be a good feminist say or to feel
like a good modern or a good Progressive
or something you'll probably still say
in public like yeah I wanna I wanna date
another I want to date a feminist you
know like I I want to date someone who
is evolved I need to date a man who goes
to therapy
is that actually true you you may not be
true but like who's going to go out
there in public and say like yeah I want
to I want to date like a throwback I
want to date a caveman that's my
preference as a modern woman and worry
about being looked at sideways again
going back to this sort of like people
who talk about like the men problem it's
like oh are you one of questionable
it's a branding problem that's what the
manosphere fundamentally doesn't need to
do more YouTube live streams what it
needs is to hire a marketing agency
that's to have a really really good
rebranding agency and if you manage to
do that then all of the typically
masculine guys would be getting laid
more as well because they wouldn't be so
besmirched by whatever the sort of
culture is saying about them but yeah
you you nail it I think I had a really
great conversation that I'll send to you
once I'm done it'll be up um later this
week with a guy called George who runs
the Tin Men on Instagram British British
dude Unapologetic from the left presents
in a like not super masculine way uh but
is absolutely like vehemently pro-men
and it's so interesting talking to
someone that's a card-carrying liberal
who also is unforgiving in how pro-male
he is talking about the problems of male
suicide homelessness incarceration
Family Court all of the things that you
should not be talking about and I spoke
to him like why is it that the left
don't want to kind of acknowledge this
problem there's like either an inability
or an unwillingness for mainstream media
and the left in general to advocate for
men and you nailed it you had this
really great quote where you say many
progressives have ignored the
opportunity to sell men on a better
vision of what they could be and it is
the point that if you do not like the
current role models that are being put
up for men you need to offer them
something else it's not just a case that
you can leave the vacuum and then start
throwing your toys out of the pram
because oh Andrew Tates Bugatti like I
can't believe he smokes cigars and
drinks bottled water like you can't
complain about that unless you're going
to say and here is something that I
propose instead of that because men are
going to find someone they need
someone
simply abandoning them is precisely the
reason why the right has dominated this
conversation
right that's a thing and I say this
often in this in this sort of
conversation in the fight between
something and nothing
something
is always going to win like it may be a
very bad something but like you're not
offering anything else then of course
people go to what's on offer
um and yeah what's on offer right now is
like pretty bad it's not even I mean
when you talk about Andrew Kate it's or
entertain it's not just he talked about
his Bugattis it's that he's a literal
sex trafficker but again
alleged sex trafficker Christine sure
that's true that's true I am a
journalist he is an alleged sex
trafficker
um and also admits it in his own words
but
um yeah who is who is the opposing
figure that you're telling men to to go
out and seek who are you providing if
you're from the left and think that
that's a bad option and just sort of
like closing your eyes and wishing that
these people would go away is
unfortunately not going to do it
I mean another conflict I think too
and I've heard this from a lot of
commenters from the piece and people
have written to me is the idea that okay
well if you define masculinity and
femininity or Define masculinity first
you're isn't it that you're kind of
saying that the good things about being
a man say men are more risk-taking or
men are more competitive or stronger are
you saying that you know women
don't take risks and can't be strong and
if men are interested in leadership does
that mean women have to be followers and
I think people are perhaps justifiably
afraid of putting people back into boxes
that they've only recently broken out of
and then okay if you have this one
definition of masculinity that's all
about say aggression and risk taking and
sex drive Etc
what about the men who don't fit into
that you know and I had a great debate
with um my colleague Jonathan capart and
he was like you know in this masculinity
debate like I'm a gay married guy like
this traditional masculine like I'm not
John Wayne I was never going to be John
Wayne so sometimes when this debate is
going on I feel like it's not for me
like that one model of mentalness is not
capacious enough and so actually one of
the things that I think will be key
going forward for those who want to put
forward like a better view of manhood
and masculinity and better role models
is also to have not just one role model
or One Vision of masculinity like
ideally there are many good ways to be a
man as many ways as there are men and by
having more and different role models of
masculinity like more people can find a
way but you still have to have those
models right you can't just be like be
good
and that's yeah so this is a really
important point that I think we need to
get into
I'm not convinced that there are as many
ways to be a good man as there are men
and this came out of a debate that I had
in Qatar a couple of months ago I flew
to Qatar to debate a gentleman who is a
member of the LGBT community but he's
also a Kuwaiti born American that's
pro-palestine and I think religious in
in some form as well so it's an
interesting sort of blend of yeah
exactly and I could see he had this
concept called The Man box that I
thought was really interesting and he
said that basically the man box is this
prescriptive way of describing what a
man can be if you're within this you are
a man if you're outside of this you're
not a man and if you make the box too
narrow and if you make the walls of it
too rigid it ends up causing many people
who sit outside of the box in terms of
their predisposition to feel like
they're dispossessed and they're not
included and this is a guy who um Wanted
to Dance as a kid who growing up at
least with some of the influences of an
Arabic culture would have absolutely
felt dispossessed and displaced right I
can totally see that yeah totally what I
came to realize is that yes there isn't
just one way to be a good man but there
can't be an unlimited number of ways
either because the problem of breaking
open the expectations of being a man so
much
that there are no longer any provides
zero guidance on for men's and boys on
men and boys on how to behave there has
to be some limitations because you are
defined by the boundaries of whatever it
is that you're going to do if being a
good man means that you can be anything
if you can continue to redefine and
redefine and redefine that means that
it's the same as it being nothing there
is no definition if the definition can
be anything
so Yes actually I do think that's right
so I should revise that I would say I
mean when I say I think that there are
as many ways to be a good man as there
are to be a man it's like any person is
capable of being a good person and like
what it looks like to be a good person
as you specifically is different from
is me specifically but it's also clear
that like you're a man and I am a woman
so there's those are just going to be
different I think it's really important
to recognize that people do actually
need boundaries and need role models and
Norms that are specific especially when
they're younger and so this is an
interesting thing
um that I found reading responses to
this piece like we only have comments
open for three days and there were ten
thousand five hundred comments on this
piece nuts Did you sort it by most liked
almost commented did you see what that
top one was
um I haven't today what what's the top
one the top one today it seems like it's
been around for a long time so I'm gonna
guess that you'll have seen this one was
um I don't know what you're talking
about this doesn't resonate with me at
all
that yes so that was what I was going to
say they're like comments from I think
more like older men not old men but like
men in there maybe 40s and 50s so many
of them are like I don't know what the
problem is with masculine like I'm fine
and it's the younger man who's like oh
this really resonates like I've been
struggling with this too and I think
I actually do think what's happening is
is specific to younger men because when
you're younger you simply don't know as
much and so you kind of need a road map
or a path to start from like at least a
basic Norm that you start from
acknowledging and then as you grow up
and you get more experience and you
figure out where you fit in the world
it's like you sort of begin to expand
and like figure out how that Norm fits
you right like there's a path and like
as you become your own person you Branch
out
um but there has to be a starting point
you know there what is a man like
there's kind of a basic starting point
that you you'll start from and then as
you figure it out you become your own
person but there has to be at least some
baseline some original norm and so I
think that's what I'm saying like there
there needs to be like a baseline okay A
man is X like how do you be a good man
like it includes these things and what
does that look like in your own life
like that may vary depending on your
profession whether you're married etc
etc but you start from here and I worry
sometimes that you know the push is that
like well everyone is so different like
there is no Baseline exactly what you're
a good person I'm not a good man yeah
and that doesn't tell you anything
yeah no I I think you're right and it's
it's a shame that we've got this thing
called gamma bias did you come across
this you describe it in the in your
piece but I don't know whether you came
across the term no okay so I I think
that you explain
um
if there is something which is ardently
pro-female it's very heavily gendered if
there's something that's oddly Pro male
it gets desexed right and the reverse is
also true so
um a male killer male serial killer if
if it was a female which you probably
almost certainly wouldn't be but um if
it was a female it would it regularly
gets desexed this is by John Barry from
the center for um male psychology and he
calls it gamma bias which is that the
successes of men are de-gendered and the
successes of women are sexed too because
that's we're still living in a world
where the culture presumes that success
of women is a an outlier or an
aberration what successful women serial
killer
um
yeah but you you end up with this
situation in which uh there is a
vacuum of uh positive examples of
masculinity he is this this really great
example where um Sarah everard you
remember that case it was in the UK it
was this a woman who was horrifically uh
sort of followed home and killed by a
British police officer and there was you
know candlelit vigils and people in the
streets and blah blah blah blah and
horrific like absolutely horrific story
the next week A man jumped into the
Thames to try and save a woman that was
drowning and it didn't even say man in
the headline
and it was like person jumps into River
to try and save woman dies
um so again John seems to have done the
work to have been able to show that this
is replicated and I don't really think
that there's a broader conspiracy here
other than it's commonly uploaded in the
media to be like Yay women and kind of
less popular to be like Yay man so what
do they do well they just lean into what
they presume is going to be popular and
that seems to make sense you know we've
ex explained today how many different
hurdles you had to jump through to make
sure that you didn't trigger any of the
different tripwires and defense
mechanisms that would have potentially
caused your article to be misinterpreted
so it's evident that these things still
exist
but I do worry that
by doing that what what is left as a a
positive role model for men and as you
said the formative year is a formative
for a reason right like these are the
times when you're looking for like okay
what should I do I'm confused and for
the you know the gentleman that
commented on your piece saying
I don't know what you're talking about
all I spend my time doing is going to
work and looking after my kids and and
you know like I I get up on time and I
do the things yeah but where do you
think that you've got those rules and
guidelines from like okay it's not about
your problem right now the goal of much
of sort of men's education and General
Life Education overall is to get
yourself moving to the stage where you
can kind of pedal on your own two feet
it's okay and now I have some of the
advice the stabilizers have been taken
off and I can kind of weave my own life
path with the understanding that I've
got this these foundations behind me
yeah
yeah yeah no exactly I mean also one of
the things that uh so I interviewed
Richard Reeves and Scott Galloway among
other sort of experts for this piece and
one of the things that Scott said really
resonated with me he said that this is
first of all that this is an ongoing
problem that's not going to be fixed
overnight and part of it unfortunately
or not unfortunately but just truthfully
is a problem of responsibility like men
do have to decide to
be better and to you know work on
themselves that said it's also the
responsibility of
older men and Community Role Models like
the 50 year old guy who's like my life
is great I'm a great man okay cool like
go teach another young man how to do
that
um because so much of this learning is
also
and I think this is I think that this is
different in some way for for men almost
than it is for women much of it does
come from role modeling from having
someone to look up to so like there's
research that I cite in the piece um
from this Landmark study by Raj Shetty
and it was actually about economic
Mobility
um in different neighborhoods he studied
this by ZIP code but there were a lot of
sort of interesting side findings in the
work and one of them was that for black
boys specifically economic Mobility
tended to be much lower and actually a
lot of the difference in economic
Mobility by race between white and black
was due to the kind of poor performance
of boys who were black but
he found that if these boys lived in a
neighborhood that had more fathers
present and not even their own fathers
just like more dads around somebody
else's dad whatever they were far more
likely to achieve economic mobility and
so like the just the presence of Role
Models had a huge effect and there's
other research showing that boys are
just much more affected by the presence
of good figures in young age too there's
a sort of daisies versus dandelions
model where you know girls even when
they're brought up in adverse
circumstances tend to be pretty
resilient and can bounce back you know
their date they're dandelions they grow
through the cracks they just like make
it work but actually and perhaps
unexpectedly little boys are daisies if
they have adverse experiences if they
don't have good Role Models when they're
younger they're much less likely to
bounce back they just Wilt and so to
raise good men like men other men an
older man Mal who have been successful
and are comfortable in their masculinity
need to take it upon themselves to be
part of the solution
really amazing Point first thing that
come up comes up for me is so
interesting that that guy that commented
that said that everything in his life
was fine I don't know what you're
talking about his first Port of Call was
to go to atomized individuation
he was talking about me I'm okay as
opposed to wow maybe there's some truth
to this and maybe as somebody that feels
comfortable in their own masculinity and
like he's got his life together I
shouldn't reach out and say can't
believe that this is happening would
love to try and help someone that's a
young man that's suffering because I
feel like I've managed to find my place
in the world
second thing being I'm increasingly
certain that a lot of the problems that
we're seeing especially amongst uh
misbehavior but also when it comes to
academic outcomes especially black inner
city youths are
very very heavily laid at the feet of
single-parent households it's like many
of the problems we're seeing are
fatherless problems as opposed to
culture problems or I guess father
listeners could be born out of culture
but you know what I mean like yeah like
that and I wonder whether
part of the masculinity crisis is
Downstream from an increasing number of
single-parent households I wonder if you
could conduct a sufficiently big study
to work out are men or young boys who
grew up in a two-parent household
more or less likely to say that they
don't know what a real man is that they
struggle it would be insane if it wasn't
the case it would be absolutely why that
would be a much more shocking Revelation
than it was but until we've got the data
it's just bro signs
but yeah I think um
it the single parent problem the lack of
strong father figures again is exactly
why we need good Role Models out there
which is why you know in a age of social
media ubiquity you are going to
gravitate towards someone I know that I
found this you know I got toward the end
of my 20s probably a little bit late to
try and stop being an adult infant but I
get to you know 27 28 29 and I've
achieved a good bit of success in the
way that Society tells a young man that
he maybe should but I didn't feel like I
understood myself I didn't feel like I
had a good conception of who I was or
what I really should do I didn't have a
firm foundation on how I should show up
in the world and then I see this old
like wizard Druid looking Canadian
psychology Professor on a bald MMA
commentators podcast and I go oh wow
this guy's telling me to tell the truth
wow what a radical idea to actually not
lie to try and get things that you want
out of people but to focus on telling
the truth instead of X and Y and Z and
then you speak to like people like Sam
Harris or a land about on from the
school of life you know all of these
different interesting people who had
insights
that weren't necessarily about
masculinity but were about
psychology and we're about the world and
the way that the World shows up and from
that you infer what being a good person
and being a good man is and um
yeah it's I I one of the things I'm most
interested in especially given that
you've written this and now you've got
all of this sort of attention you must
have been able to look at the current
landscape of how these conversations are
being had previously it's not like
you're the first person ever to talk
about this
what do you think most commentators are
missing when they try to talk about the
problem of boys and men
well
go on at length
um
I mean first kind of does tack back to
what you were saying about single parent
households again I think in modern
society and Progressive spaces
especially there is this bias towards
inclusivity everybody chooses their own
life path and that's okay they're all
great they're all of equal value we
don't want to stigmatize anyone but
actually I'm I feel quite certain that
maybe the question the specific question
is like
the specific question are you unsure of
your masculinity may not have been asked
but there's so much data that shows that
children in single parent households and
especially fatherless households
tend to do worse and especially boys
when it comes to exactly what you're
saying about discipline and academic
achievement like the data does show this
very clearly
um but there is a reluctance I think
among many commentators to say that
um or to point out that that could be a
problem because it's seen as
stigmatizing you know to the
single-parent households yeah and I mean
that comes from sort of oversensitivity
and also maybe just a a sort of
acceptance that this seems to be more
common like this is the way things are I
guess
um and so like that it's not offered as
a solution that men should be better
fathers and stay with their fathers and
that there should be more two-parent
households but that is just an an
obviously important part of this problem
um I interviewed as I said it a bunch of
young men for this piece and almost all
of them
said that you know oh like one thing
about this is like I had a really crappy
relationship with my dad like my dad was
a terrible person or he wasn't around
and actually all of my friends like very
few of us can say that we had good
relationships with our fathers and so
like maybe that has something to do with
it I don't know and you know they're not
sure but it it seems very clear
and actually like there was one young
man who I spoke to and I didn't get to
include this part
um in the essay but he was like yeah I
had a shitty relationship with my my dad
actually and I was kind of allowed like
I was not a very good man and actually
what changed for me was when
um this priest in my neighborhood uh who
officiated my dad's funeral actually
just sort of took me under his wing and
like taught me how to cook and just like
hung out with me as a man and that was
the role model I needed to become you
know a better person the person that I
am today but that was somebody who just
sort of saw a lost young man and was
like I'm just gonna
care for him and be a model to him and
teach him how to grow up
um so I think I do think that that is
one thing that commentators are either
missing or purposefully not speaking
about and I think that that's a real
problem and I do think that when people
try and speak about it you know like
Barack Obama had the sort of My
Brother's Keeper program and had several
speeches about dads and missing dads and
he was often sort of shouted down for
being a scold even though
he was right
um
I think also that this question of
representation is important actually and
actually this has become kind of a
buzzword in Progressive and liberal
space is the idea that representation is
important like women need to see
themselves in spaces like people of
color need to see themselves in spaces
but when you look at what the data shows
about men in formative spaces for men
um there are very few male uh
Primary School teachers and secondary
school teachers there are actually very
few male nurses as you said male
psychologists and
imagine if you're you know a boy growing
up in a single parent household you're
raised by your mom you go through the
average public school system average
public medical system in the U.S you may
really never see a man in a position of
teaching Authority until you know you're
an adult what does that
do really and so perhaps a policy
solution might be to kind of acknowledge
that and try to figure out how to get
men into some of these spaces and some
of the problem there is that these
spaces are considered feminized because
there's so many women in them and that
makes it harder to recruit men to those
spaces but
I don't know there has to be
some way to do that there
um
yeah I mean those are those are just two
things actually there are
a number more but
the role modeling yeah both of those are
huge
um a couple of the conversations I've
had one with uh Max Rudd last year
um this is a guy who was going to get
married and I think he'd gone he's
always had female friends
um but you tend to have more girlfriends
than guy friends
and he went to get his suit fitted I
think or something like that maybe get
fitted for the ring that he was going to
wear and uh the girl friend that he was
with said so who's going to be your best
man
and he said uh
uh it'll come to me don't don't worry
and he got home and he realized [__]
like where are all of my male friends he
didn't have any he didn't have a guy
that could be his best man at his
wedding and one of the things that he
discovered it was more to do with the
loneliness epidemic for men there but
that
um men's only spaces were seen as these
sort of vaulted Halls of power that was
exclusionary to women specifically and
this means that we need to break open
the doors because you know I'm a female
Barrister and I want to make sure that
there isn't a secret Boys Club somewhere
so that I can be included because I also
want to become a judge or at some higher
sort of legal person but like okay
that's true but if Downstream from that
like working Men's Clubs and stuff and
and men's sheds which is this initiative
coming out of Australia where men older
men
um
fix [__] together and fixing [__]
together in a in a shed literally called
men's sheds I'm sure it's coming out of
Australia they just fix stuff so
there'll be a a bench or a car or a
lawnmower or something and these guys
just come together because men Bond over
doing stuff you know I see this in my
own life I one of my best friends one of
my longest standing friends who's my old
business partner from my my nightclub
days I'm still Incredibly Close I was a
groomsman at his wedding all of this
stuff but now that I do the podcast full
time
our relationship is in a different
bucket it's it's one of of nostalgia and
a huge amount of love but it doesn't
have that same sort of dopamine and that
kind of Rush that I do with my editor
Dean for instance who's been with me for
five and a half years and it's every
single day it feels like going to war
with someone feels like standing
shoulder to shoulder in fact that's a
Richard Reeves thing right where he says
yeah that uh what is it women women Bond
face to face men Bond shoulders side by
side yeah no that is that is actually
the right third point that I was kind of
forgetting it's that is kind of a cliche
the side to side versus shoulder
shoulder thing but I mean it's a cliche
because it does seem kind of true and
this also I think sort of throws it back
to the question of why aren't why are
there so many women commentators on this
problem in a way uh I do think that
women spend more time face-to-face sort
of therapizing about like the problems
where men may have the same problem but
they're just doing stuff together like
they're not like tell me your problems
like let's just like look at each other
over some wine and like talk about our
problems
[Laughter]
dangerous for one thing
um
but this the single
the single spaces question I think is a
really interesting one and a really
touchy one in this moment and I think it
is a really important one too
um so I think the last big conversation
about it was when the Boy Scouts
um became open to all Sexes instead of
just being the Boy Scouts and I actually
think that we may look back on that
um and realize that it was a mistake so
like one of the reasons why it would be
helpful to have more uh male teachers in
primary and secondary school is because
male teachers often end up being the
coaches for boys sports and boys only
Sports and often those are the places
where like young men are sort of side by
side I don't know moving stuff around
Rook beef from a woman no guy no boy
seven-year-old boy wants to learn rugby
from they want to get code in mud and
get pushed over by a big dude right
yeah I think that's true actually for
sure but I mean there is a continuing
like lack of and dismissal of the need
for those spaces and so one of the
things that I wrote about in the piece I
cite that sociologist David Gilmore who
did this big survey of masculinity over
like a broad number of cultures on
multiple continents and so he came up
with a sort of protector provider
procreator Paradigm like this is sort of
the the understanding that almost every
culture shares about what it means to be
a man and being a man is different from
being male and that was the other thing
like you can be born male but you have
to become a man and in most societies it
seems like there's almost a kind of
initiation process into becoming a real
man that's led by older men in your
community who sort of like would take a
boy away and like teach him how to be a
man and then he does stuff with them and
he comes back an adult and that happens
in male only spaces is or on the sports
field or at War and we have fewer and
fewer of those like specifically male
only
bonding spaces right now and you know
it's easy to say well well that's good
like exactly as you were saying we can't
just like have all the men go to the
strip club and bond together
um and leave women out
well the women are involved the women
are heavily involved in the strip club I
don't know how many strip clubs you've
been to Christine the women are a
fundamental part of that process
I'll take your word I'll take your word
for that for a future podcasts okay okay
so
um yeah you're right there there aren't
as many of those spaces and that is
actually maybe a major loss and we have
to think about what it would look like
to rebuild that process of initiation
that process of role modeling
um yeah I think the other thing as well
is that
men's friendships are
uh more flimsy in terms of the
one-on-one than women's are
um men's friendship groups will have
someone come and go you know Jim has
been coming to the pub with you and your
three mates every Friday for the last
decade but Jim's going to move to
Thailand so Jim's gone and now Mike's in
Mike you're the new gym like hope you
like it and that's the way that men's
friendships work that's literally the
way that their friendships work because
ancestrally if you were going to go out
with a small cohort of your guys and try
and take down a wildebeest or a woolly
mammoth and one of he gets gored you're
going to be very sad for quite a while
but you can't be completely despondent
forever because you need to keep
cracking on and doing the things whereas
for women if you're aloe parenting if
you're doing shared uh child rearing
between you and your girlfriends you
need to make damn sure that you trust
them you need to be incredibly tight and
the likelihood of that cycling through
would have been significantly less
interesting in a
um like Patra Patra local uh Society I
actually wonder how that would have
worked because obviously women were
often sort of
um pick picked up and moved to the new
husband's location so that that actually
kind of throws a spanner in it but that
Insight is from Robin Dunbar and this
one is for as well they're talking about
the shoulder to shoulder or face-to-face
thing so the next time that you go to a
party
if you look around if it's like a house
party and people are just talking or
whatever look around at the way that men
and women are standing so if you look at
the angle of the feet that women have
it's almost exactly perpendicular right
so it's it's the same essentially if you
look at the angle that men stand at on
average they stand at the angle of 120
degrees so you could draw a line like
that it would be like this and men do
they blade so you stand kind of like
this and the other one's standing kind
of like that
buzz dunbar's argument is that really
the only time that guys stand face to
face is if they're going to fight
because you're able to fully size them
up it also makes you look the widest and
if you do if you're a guy you can prove
this to yourself the next time that you
go to a party try and close that
whatever 60 degree Gap and try and stand
front on and it's either going to lead
you out weird and weird the guy out yeah
it looks like you're either gonna fight
him or kiss him those are the two
options and they're both kind of weird
in the moment yeah
yeah
but if you try and do it it just feels
like
oh yeah this is I can't this is natural
so so obviously one of the things that
we kind of danced around so far and you
make a big deal of in the article which
I think is is really important is that
the writing around the crisis of
masculinity
firmly stops at the diagnosis stage they
refuse either purposefully or just
through like uh ignorance to try and put
forward a concrete vision for what men
should be why do you think it is the
case that the diagnosis stage is as far
as anyone's prepared to go
yeah I mean Richard Roose talks about
this in the article and he makes the
point that we talked about earlier that
there is kind of a branding problem if
you spend too much time like thinking
about men and like trying to fix the men
problem you get the kind of like um
questionable what are you up to do you
have like some sort of hidden misogynist
agenda
um thing but
then also there is the also what we
talked about this idea that
you know we don't need to have special
roles for men you know we just need to
be good people no one wants to be
prescriptive about what a man should be
for fear of not being inclusive enough
and leaving someone out or offending
someone else
um just like nobody really wants to take
the risk
um but actually one of my interview
subjects made the point that I think is
is really important and really hard and
one that I think we're gonna have to
think about for a while which is that
these problems didn't just start
overnight
and so the solution is not going to be
overnight like there's not just going to
be a fix for this you know the problem
of or maybe not a problem but just the
fact of globalization and
de-industrialization like that happened
it took years
um and now like this has really shifted
the economics of being a man especially
a working class man to figure out what
comes after that is a big question you
know this question of uh single parent
homes and fatherlessness or a lack of
role models
you can't just grow a father overnight
you know it's it's not as easy as just
like uh well we're just gonna plop a
strange man in your community and now
you have a role model
um this is a problem where you know kids
have grown up fatherless and maybe their
fathers who are now missing had negative
father figures themselves who didn't
really teach them how to be a man and
you know it's it's kind of like we've
cut off
sort of patriarchy and these old Norms
off at the knees and now there's sort of
like an open field of what are we
supposed to do but growing back a a tree
in the field is not something that
happens overnight these are generational
problems and
to come up with a better idea of
masculinity or even just an idea of what
masculinity is period that fits in this
moment
it's just going to be a norm shift right
and Norms are society-wide and they take
time the women's movement achieved a ton
but the women's movement has also been
sort of at work for the past
60 years you know and those gains have
come over time not overnight so I think
I think it's hard to prescribe I mean I
think that the short term is that it's
hard to prescribe because people are
frankly scared to say and I write about
this more broadly in my work I think
people are really scared of norms of
saying that like there is a right way to
do something and there is a wrong way to
do something or there is a good there is
a bad or there is male and there is
female because someone is always in
between and nobody wants to hurt
anyone's feelings but also it's just
it's complicated and it's about
relationships and you can't
sort of you can't really policy fix
relationships you know like Joe Biden
isn't going to pass a law that suddenly
fathers have to go back to their homes
relationships are things that you build
from the bottom up
yeah the inclusivity definitely seems to
be at odds with its instructionality in
this regard uh that the more inclusive
you may again it's the man box you
expanded out sufficiently and you you
actually have nothing left there are no
guide guidelines
at all
I do
wonder about the
like the cultural uh nudges something
that's really interesting is if you look
at what the feminist movement first and
second wave we're really trying to do
they were trying to change culture
so that they could achieve something
structurally right that we need women to
be accepted in the workplace so that
women can go to the workplace what's
happening with masculinity is that men
have been displaced from the workplace
and now need to find a place in the
culture do you understand do you think
this makes sense that the con it's
almost like the reverse of what the
Civil Rights Movement we want to have
the equal rights for people of color so
that they can work because that's the
thing that we're trying to get
and they both occur at the same time
whereas this conversation around
masculinity is actually more like
the broad-based to brain-based economy
change the increased use of
credentialism when it comes to jobs and
boys
disadvantage predisposition disadvantage
that they have around that means that
culture is now trying to reverse
engineer a version of masculinity to fit
this new structure to fit the change
yeah
yeah and I I think we have a lot less
experience with doing that and also our
culture continues to move super fast
actually so almost as soon as we have
identified one problem like a new and
crops up like even if we were thinking
of okay oh here are men they seem to
have a lot of time on their hands
because the economy has changed what do
we do with them then suddenly it's
supercharged by like oh porn it's
everywhere video games like the internet
and new Role Models have also changed
the way that we shake personalities and
shape people so like what do we do with
that in addition to catching up with
this old problem
um so yeah I think the roots too towards
the routes towards teaching are
different is it going to be through
schools we don't I think invest as much
Authority in our schools anymore it used
to be through perhaps religious
institutions people are increasingly
becoming less religious and like less
involved in their Community organization
so like where do you even go to start
and I think
I think those are questions that we'll
be weighing it on too
one thing that I would definitely say as
a starting point you know having spent a
lot of time a good chunk of the audience
is male a good chunk of them are in that
age bracket who do still probably need a
good chunk of guidance
the first thing
I would say the first prescription is to
stop talking about men and the problems
of boys and men in a way that causes
them to check out because regardless of
what you try to do Downstream from that
this is the gateway drug that opens all
the rest of them up
the the cultural temperature is that men
have always had it great therefore the
men of today need to pay for the sins
and advantages of their fathers and
grandfathers
basically I you've had it good for so
long that we don't really need to worry
about you or anything that you do is
toxic or any whichever different
permutation of that happens it causes
men to check out so regardless of what
you try to do in terms of structure you
know we've got these interesting
initiatives and we go to so on and so
forth
I don't think that's going to work the
second part is that
when pretty much any group has a problem
in society we don't tell them that they
fix it by trying to open up about their
problems we spend billions and billions
of dollars in taxpayer money to try and
work out what's going on to create
initiatives and incentives and to change
structure so that it actually warps the
world around them if any other group has
a problem we say what can we do to
change the world to fix it but if men
have a problem we say why aren't men
fixing themselves yeah pull yourself up
by your bootstraps bio it's time to go
and get it done and the problem is that
you know a lot of masculinity and a lot
of men that is an attractive proposition
you know the Sovereign highly sovereign
agentic individual that can forge his
own way I'm a Pioneer I'm A Lone Ranger
I can go and do this and you even see
this get caricatured you know the sigma
male Lone Wolf meme that's being the
Giga Chad's like Sigma male name that
floats around the internet is precisely
that taken to it's extreme right I'm go
that's what mgtow is that's what men
going the runway is it's in cell is the
similar but in Reverse where I'm just
going to Cast Away from the world that's
still you going out on your own but
you're you're putting it into a
direction that typically wouldn't have
been seen as productive so yeah I think
we need to be very very cautious around
pointing the finger at men
in fact men would be happy I think to
have the finger pointed at them and say
you guys can do better you can do better
and we're going to help you do better
but if you say you can do better and you
feel like you've been dispossessed and
cast out from society castigated from
society
you're gonna go [__] you like okay yeah
I'm useless and toxic and cool whatever
like I'm just gonna wank and smoke weed
and play Call of Duty like that's what
that's what the rest of my years got in
store for me yeah that's that's a really
important distinction too
um I think that a positive vision of
masculinity has to be aspirational right
like it has to be
positive meaning it's it's something
you're you're achieving something that
you like go out and find and that it's
good for you to find and I feel like one
of the things that makes the Jordan
Petersons and uh Andrew takes the world
feel sort of exciting and like people
who you want to follow is that they
actually make manhood feel like
something good and achieving it is kind
of like a quest that you go on and at
the end you have this good thing it's
not like fix what's broken about you
it's like no I'm calling you to more and
calling you to hire and I have high
expectations for you and you're going to
beat them and I think we need more of
that energy in our masculinity discourse
not like you're toxic stop being so
toxic but like actually men are good
like a good man is a good thing and like
you can do that go do that one of the
things that that was really surprising
about or surprising to me in the
response to my article was the number of
people who described it as empathetic
and we're like it kind of seems like
you'd like like men it's like actually I
do yeah like I like men I want them to
be better because like I want
people all people but my male friends
like romantic Partners family members
to be happy and I think just like the
sheer impact of having a piece that
wasn't like men are terrible and here's
why but like framing it is like what's
the problem how can we do better
just like being even slightly like
neutral to positive instead of neutral
to negative seem to have a huge impact
well it shows how low the bar is
for positive male discourse online for
it to be oh my God like you didn't call
me a piece of [__] you're I'm in love
with you thank you so much yeah
um so talking about that what we
mentioned that your piece has got an
author it's only been out just over a
week it's got an awful lot of attention
more after this episode as well
um thanks what has been
the feedback
or the the criticisms that you've got
from the left or from the more
Progressive side of the aisle
huh um I mean again this
the sort of like the box is too narrow
question has come up again and again
like whoa well if you say that we have
to be masculine or like manhood what are
you what are you calling manhood maybe I
don't fit maybe people don't fit what
about those people
which
I don't on the one hand like I get it I
get that as a pushback but everything
isn't for everyone like there's no
prescription that fits every single
person I'm sorry that's just the world
so there's that
um there are still a number of
reflexive
responses from I think people who didn't
finish reading the piece or maybe
haven't gotten to the section who
shouldn't have made it responding to I
know it's it's my fault I'll self-blame
um but who are like men men again we're
still talking about men
screw men you know like the piece is
kind of about how we need to stop doing
that and yet that is still a response
and I'm getting to this piece uh like uh
we've already talked about the crisis of
masculinity like we don't need to keep
going there but it's a real crisis so
we're gonna keep going there until we
figure out what's going on
for anyone that thinks that this isn't a
big deal
please explain to me why this post has
had so much popularity
like if it wasn't a big deal why would
anybody be bothered about reading it and
sharing it
um and yeah you know I'm part way
through this this book writing process
at the moment where I'm tackling an
equally icky topic of the mating crisis
and
we are I'm finding myself
falling over my own words in a desperate
attempt to not try and Trigger some of
the antibody responses from uh different
groups because I really think that it's
an important discussion and I really
want as many people as possible to have
their eyes opened to what we're talking
about and yet
there are upper bounds that I'm just
unprepared to cross when it comes to
writing the piece so I know for a fact
that there are there's going to be an
awful lot of criticism and very very
upset news articles online
because I can't warp the facts to suit
everybody's worldview I can't change the
I I can't change the reality around the
situation and this one of my friends
said it to me the other day that
basically uh it no matter what you say
it's impossible to please everybody
regardless of what you try and put out
you can put out the most well-meaning
well-reasoned heavily caveat and there
are going to be a huge number of people
especially given a large enough audience
that are going to take massive offense
to whatever it is that you've said so I
think that you've done a good job of of
really trying to um dance through the
Minefield of tripwires on on both of the
different sides
um you know I I definitely do think that
the next stage for this will be
making it culturally accepted to talk
about the fact that men and boys are
struggling once you do that you can
include them in the conversation you
then need to try and put forward
something that looks like a positive
Vision that includes actual role models
that includes famous people and people
of in positions of renown who have
Lifestyles that are both aspirational
and inspirational that men can look up
to that they can pedestalize and that
they can try and follow you don't need
to love all of them you know but you
need to have at least a couple that you
probably can afford to love and not
everyone needs to agree but like okay
again that conversation I had in Qatar I
asked the gentleman sad opposite me
um I know that you don't like Jordan
Peterson and Joe Rogan as examples of
what you think a man should be can you
please give me an example of someone
that you do and it took 10 seconds for
him to say my brother-in-law and I said
well how about somebody that we all know
and it it was a mean comment but I think
it was important to really drive home
the fact that it is difficult to
if you are from a certain political
leaning to put that point forward
um yeah no that's that's something that
I experienced too actually like when I
also sort of went out on the streets
like there's a video that goes with the
article and asks men about these
questions and who is their role model
and so much of so much of our discourse
is politicized that I think men who
might objectively be good Role Models
whether it's like a Barack Obama or a
Mitt Romney
um people just like don't want to say
that because it might be seen as like
rooting for the other team somehow and
that's and that's not allowed and also
again the the specificity question I do
think that that
the sort of like we don't need to be we
don't need a good masculine we just need
to be good people uh there's pushback to
the idea that like there are masculine
traits but again we can't warp the world
to fit people's beliefs like
unfortunately I I just do think that
there are and to be able to make a
prescription we have to recognize those
facts and speak to them
Christine Ember ladies and gentlemen
Christine I really appreciate you uh
let's have another conversation at some
point soon about rethinking sex as well
I think that would be absolutely
fascinating to talk about the Fallout
from me too and consent and ceilings and
flaws and whatnot but if people want to
check out more of the stuff that you do
where should they go
alas you can find me anywhere so um you
can follow me at the Washington Post
um I'm on Twitter threads Instagram as
Christine emba uh just my full name and
I will shortly be launching a sub stack
um so you can also follow that at
christinemba.substack.com good stuff
Christine I really appreciate you thank
you so much for having me great
conversation if you enjoyed that episode
then press here for a selection of the
best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe